before Brad Pitt became one of the
biggest stars in the world he made his
television debut in 1987 on another
world what's your name okay Chris yes
Brad only appeared in two episodes but
it marked his first speaking role who
would have guessed 33 years later Brad
would take home his first Oscar for
acting in Quentin Tarantino's Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood Owen Brad's co-star
in that film Margot Robbie she began her
career on the small screen in the
Australian soap neighbors as Donna for
over 350 episodes
It's like a dream it's my dream Margot
recently returned to make a cameo on the
series finale of the soap Sarah Michelle
Geller may be best known for the hit
series Buffy the Vampire Slayer but
Sarah's breakout role was playing
Kendall Hart on All My Children have you
know Shane
I didn't come here to make a scene all I
want is just a few minutes alone to say
goodbye to my grandmother in 1994 Sarah
told Entertainment Tonight she couldn't
believe she was on the show told me two
years ago I would have been Erica Kane's
daughter and all my children I would
have gone no way no way in 1995 Sarah
won a Daytime Emmy Award for her
performance on the series
before John Stamos was known as Uncle
Jesse on Full House he got his start in
the business from 1982 to 1984
portraying the resident bad boy on
General Hospital I wish they got what I
deserved on buddy one of Oscar winner
Julianne Moore's first roles was
actually two starting in 1985 Julianne
played half-sisters Franny and Sabrina
on As the World Turns in a Daytime Emmy
award-winning role I've been trying to
find you for months
what do you want in 2010 Julianne
returned as Franny to make a cameo on
the series
from one more to another Shemar Moore's
star-making role on The Young and the
Restless began in 1994. Shamar played
Malcolm Winters on the show for over 10
years
E.T was on set with Shamar in 2014 when
he made a return to Genoa City pulling
up into the lot and walking through the
hallways getting on the other so so much
has changed but so much is the same and
Demi Moore's first television role was
in 1982 playing journalist Jackie
Templeton on General Hospital you don't
get killed in the hospital just for your
wallet
that may be sober something was really
wrong with salt water be coming up in
the festival 41 years ago E.T caught up
with Demi who spoke about being on the
series everyone so far has been so
wonderful and so welcoming
[Music]